Bonjour, c'est Cyprien
Oui, je sais ça fait assez longtemps que j'ai pas fait de vidéos pour mon blog
Oui ça fait depuis quoi...depuis .... 2004
Ah quand même!
Il y a quelques semaines, j'ai changé d'appartement, si si, et d'ailleurs je vais vous livrer ma technique pour avoir
un appartement sur Paris
Pour avoir un appartement sur Paris, c'est extrêmement simple
Il suffit d'une seule chose
BEAUCOUP DE CHANCE!
Avant, j'habitais dans un 20 mètres carrés
À deux!
T’enlèves la salle de bain et les meubles, il te reste plus que quoi...
1 mètre carré d'espace vital.
C'est bien... 1 mètre carré
Excuse-moi, je crois que ta chaise est dans mon espace vital la...
Si, si, en fait j'ai compté les planches du parquet; t'en as 7 et j'en ai 5.
D'ailleurs pour se rendre compte de l’état du marche immobilier a Paris - ça fait très Capital (french TV show) comme phrase
"Pour se rendre compte de l’état du marché de l'immobilier à Paris..."
Bref, pour se rendre compte du délire, il fallait être la pendant l’état des lieux
de mon ancien studio
qui a duré 5 minutes pendant lesquelles il y a eu 3 visites - 3 visites en 5 minutes.
alors que le studio n'était pas encore en location.
L'avantage c'était que le studio était tellement petit que les visites allaient plutôt vite
Excusez-moi c'est bien ici la visite?
Merci, au revoir
Le truc qui me fait rire,  c'est que parfois les gens prenaient des photos de mon studio
Je vais prendre une petite photo en fait....
Ah bah c'est bon, merci
Et je suis bien content de ne plus habiter dans cette piece,
parce qu'en plus de l'espace vital relativement restreint
les murs étaient composés d'une sorte de feuille de calque en fait
quand mes voisins parlaient
j'avais l'impression d’être dans la conversation
Ah dis moi, par hasard t'aurais pas de la farine s'il te plait ?
Euh... non j'ai plus de farine non plus, désolé
Roger, écoute ca, y a le voisin, il pense qu'on lui parle, ha le blaireau!
J'entends tout en fait
Il entend tout ce qu'on dit , oh le blaireau!
Il faut savoir que les proprietaires sont les gens les plus paranos au monde
devant le gamin de sixième sens qui voit les morts
Ils te feront signer 1 milliard d'assurances pour être sûrs que tu vas bien payer ton loyer
Moi on m'avait fait signer un papier qui m'oblige à payer mon loyer
même après une catastrophe naturelle
du type météorite qui tombe et extinction de l’espèce humaine
juste au cas où...
Non, je déconne
C'est quoi ce papier alors ? Qu'est-ce que j'ai signé?
Mais tout ça c'est terminé , maintenant j'ai déménagé
Attention
j'ai une baignoire
Ça me rappelle un petit peu mon espace vital d'avant, c'est bien
Et comme vous pouvez le remarquer
j'ai très peu de décoration
C'est pas très très personnel tout ça, je le concède
Bon d'accord, j'habite dans un showroom Ikea
J'ai des cadres avec rien dedans
Je ne connais pas cette personne
Je n'ai pas de chat non plus
Par contre j'ai un petit problème avec cet appartement
au niveau de la serrure
A chaque fois que je vois ça je me dit
Pourquoi?
Peut-être que l'ancien locataire était un..... lutin
D'ailleurs ça expliquerait pourquoi j'ai un balcon monopersonnel
Peut-être qu'il y mettait toute sa famille de lutins
sur ce balcon
je sais pas
C'est tout ce que j'avais à vous dire
J'ai pas de page facebook mais j'ai un compte twitter et un blog
C'est bien aussi, non?